I have a dream that one day this nation
will rise up I have a dream that one day
people will treat immigrants the same
way that they treat everyone else I have
a dream that in the future anyone with
an accent just like mine would be able
to speak up and their voices would be as
heard as anyone elses I have a dream
that little black skinned boys and
little dark-skinned girls will grow up
loving their skin color I have a dream
that I will see people that look like me
more represented in tech and in an
engineering field I have a dream that
one day more South Asians with defy
Convention to follow their passions
because you don't need to be a lawyer
doctor or engineer to be successful I
have a dream that after our first female
president will have our first gay
president I have a dream that one day
we'll live in a society where last names
like Penn Yan Hussain will have the same
stature as Bush and Clinton I have a
dream that in the future women no matter
where they're from how much money they
make will have complete access to
reproductive health care simple as that
I have a dream that no child will ever
have to grow up without a family I have
a dream that one day systemic racism is
just eliminated one day right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we will be able to speed up that day
when all about children black men and
white men Jews and Gentiles Protestants
and Catholics will be able to join hands
and sing in the words of the old Negro
spiritual free at last free at last
thank God Almighty
[Applause]
[Applause]